This video is brought to you by surf shark, VPN.
What's up why's.
Helen coming to you from a basement slash recording studio slash end of the
world bunker. Today,
we're going to chat about a film that make you swear you to never put a ring on
it. I'm talking of course, about gone girl,
the David Fincher flick written by and based on the novel by Gillian Flynn.
We love this movie, but what's most striking about it.
Besides the shapeliness of Ben Affleck's chin is it's uniquely disturbing
conclusions about romantic relationships.
It's no wonder that gone girl is often defined mistakenly as a film whose thesis
is all women are f-ing bananas.
But what if we told you that the real message is that your love life is all a
bad theatrical production, that this is inevitable,
and there's literally nothing you can do to stop it.
Hear us out in this wisecrack edition on gone. Girl love is alive.
And of course, spoilers ahead.
Before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to surf star VPN for sponsoring today's episode of
VPN is a virtual private network that encrypts your web traffic with the VPN.
You can protect yourself from hackers snooping on your traffic,
looking to get private information like bank account pins,
or your many embarrassing urban dictionary searches.
I'm trying to keep up with whatever's in nowadays too. So I get it.
Surf shark has over 1000 servers across the globe,
and you can connect to it from your favorite device.
This also includes their additional features like clean web,
which blocks as in malware that may pop up while browsing and blind search,
which protects your browser from serving you targeted ads or sponsored sites.
If you use the link in the description right now,
you can get served shark VPN for 85% off its normal price.
Plus three extra months for free go to surf shark.deal/wisecrack,
or hit the link in the description.
Protect yourself online and download surf shark VPN today.
Now a recap meet Nick and Amy done a cool New York couple who after
getting laid off during the 2008 recession moved to Missouri to care for Nick's
ailing mother things kick off.
When Amy abruptly goes missing all suspicions immediately fall on Nick,
because that chin, as the investigation progresses,
things only looked worse for him. Turns out he's been cheating on Amy.
And also every clue basically screams this scumbag did it.
Nick insists he's innocent, but nobody not even the audience believes him.
That is until we get the midpoint reveal. Amy is not only alive,
but she plotted her entire disappearance to get back at Nick for his infidelity.
You almost gotta respect the hustle. But when Ann in hiding, Amy gets robbed.
She seeks solace in the clingy arms of her former sweetheart Desi at his creepy
Lake house. They watch Nick on live TV,
as he apologizes and figs Amy to come home in a last ditch attempt to avoid
murder charges turns out a successful media appearance is actually a huge
turn-on for our girls.
She responds to Nick's pleased by killing Desi and returning home covered in his
blood, claiming the Desi kidnapped and sexually her.
Everyone feels very sorry for Amy because she is very convincing,
very pretty, and again,
very much covered in blood except Nick knows the truth.
Amy is a murderer, but she's his murderer.
And he's in this toxic marriage for the long haul the end.
So here's a question.
Why stay with a woman who has a pathological tendency to ruin and or take the
lives of her romantic partners?
What is it that holds their bizarro love together?
Two animals I've ever known.
The answer lies in theater, play.
Hot doting husband, sweet.
Putting spouse.
Amy essentially lives her life as an actress playing the cool girl.
Nick loved a girl. I was pretending to be cool girl.
Through Amy's eventual, revisionist history.
We learned that the chill persona she put on when she and Nick first met was a
complete act.
Amy sees herself as most romantically appealing when she's pretending to be
someone she's not specifically someone who likes getting bikini waxes,
I wax trip,
essentially Nick to confesses to performing his initial cool guy self.
I met a woman who dazzled on me and I wanted a lot.
So I pretended to be better than I was.
He acts confident, funny, and able to keep up with Amy's banter. Fittingly.
Nick writes for a men's magazine. Not only is he performing to attract Amy,
but he's also teaching other men how to perform.
Yeah. Does that make you an expert on being.
No man,
appropriately Nick's wedding proposal takes the form of an uncomfortable little
show. Sure.
Surprise me. Fun fact.
You have a world-class vagina.
Awkward.
The cinematography even evokes that theatrical performance with the unfortunate
spectators framed like an audience.
So what we have here is two people explicitly enamored with their lovers acting
skills. Everyone can relate to this.
We've all tried to be a smarter funnier version of ourselves to impress a
romantic partner.
You are happy in pretending to be other people.
We were the happiest couple of winners.
But are these trivial lies or something more sinister?
The film seems to argue that particularly for women romantic expectations can
potentially be extremely deforming to the human character.
Amy describes the way she felt forced to contort herself into the cool girl to
win Nick's love and how it was both degrading and exhausting.
It's obviously an old cliche that when you pretend to be someone you're not,
you lose track of who you are. However, for Amy,
the cool girl that phenomena seems magnified. 20 fold.
This magnification you'll see is part of a pattern.
And that pattern ultimately separates Amy from the average woman who finds
interest in her boyfriend's craft beer tastes,
but even the most practiced romantic performers can get a rude awakening from
the real world. We see this when Nick and Amy get laid off in the great,
it instantly impacts their romantic performances.
They openly fret about who they might become.
It was wives who treat their men like dancing monkeys to be
trained and paraded husbands are treat their wives like the highway patrol.
Then it turns out Amy's parents need to borrow back almost her entire trust fund.
Parents publish publisher, drop them and they're in debt up to their ears.
That's terrible. And they need to borrow from my trust fund.
Thus proving their own fairytale to be the marital equivalent of fire Fest.
Afterward,
Nick basically gives up on being a husband and turns into a full-time gamer
slash shopaholic. This makes Amy occasionally act like the very not cold wife.
She dreaded becoming nagging him about money as she cleans up after him.
And then Nick's mom gets cancer,
which means the already floundering Nick and Amy show has to relocate to
Missouri. Amy feels lost out of her element. I.
Feel like something he moved in by mistake.
You can't be a cold New York media gal when you're broken Missouri fittingly,
the couple runs up anomic mansion in a rundown town that was hit hard in 2008,
leaving behind an empty neighborhood of bland homes.
Now overrun by wildlife as if to highlight the domestic ruin left in the wake of
the recession. What's more Amy struggles as a stay at home wife in the book,
Nick expressly tells the detectives that the couple have fought over
housekeeping.
This suggests that she's failing at her role and Nick isn't doing much better.
He buys a depressing bar with Amy's remaining trust fund, but it's losing money.
Doubly undercutting his attempted performance as a competent breadwinner.
The point is that neither of them is really able to convince them,
leave performable defense.
So what's a guy like Nick to do when his cool guy facade is failing and his
marriages too well. He finds a new romantic lead queue. Andy,
a younger cool girl who is both more impressionable and less intimidating than
Amy ever was. At this point.
Nick stops attempting even the most half-hearted performance of his marriage.
Instead he pulls all his energy into enjoying Andy's adoration,
even expressly reliving,
previous performative moments like when Nick wiped the snow from Andy's lifts
just as he wiped the sugar does from Amy's years ago.
It's really fitting that when carrying out as a pair,
Nick instinctively reverts back to cool guy,
the character he is most comfortable playing.
It comes more naturally than being himself. And that's a big old problem.
When Amy finds out about the affair, she's furious that he's betrayed her,
but even more so she's furious that he has successfully turned her into a cliche
clingy housewife or as bookie.
And he puts it average dumb woman married to average female, man,
this you see is a role she never wanted to play again.
It's super easy to make this all about Nick and Amy sublime dysfunction,
but we think the film is doing something more.
We think it's arguing that when someone in the early easy throws of romance
forces themselves into an unnatural mold, it all,
but dooms that relationship it's easy to perform well in the best of times.
But when a relationship is put under pressure, whether it's illness,
economic insecurity, or even a fussy new baby it's possible.
And even likely that said relationship might come on done,
but it gets worse when both participants are like Nick and Amy.
So completely used to performing that they've become out of touch with who they
really are in this case, losing the relationship means losing yourself. Again.
Many of us had been there on some level.
We just might not have experienced the spectacular fall that Nick and Amy do
still. Amy's not one to watch her marriage slowly disintegrate.
I'm not a quitter. Instead she goes straight scorched earth.
And that's when the girl goes gone.
Amy's disappearance under apparently violent circumstances,
allow her to entirely rewrite her marital history and recast the roles.
That's where her fate diary comes in in writing it.
Amy knows that the most important audience to win over is no longer Nick,
but rather the police and the public.
So she constructs a slightly massaged version of herself in her telling a
sincere loving girlfriend at becomes an innocent frightened wife who eventually
writes loose.
Man of mine.
Then when constructing Nick,
she takes her legitimate gripes that he's aloof and uncaring and dramatically
extrapolates Framingham as a scary murderous husband. Now look,
dude was a distant jerk who genuinely neglected her,
but he certainly doesn't seem to have been expressively violent or abusive.
Most importantly,
Amy's written performance draws from the very real and prevalent dynamics that
truly exists in a huge number of abusive relationships,
thus making her account more believable,
but perhaps the most satisfying thing for Amy after fleeing,
she gets to take on a new, more powerful role that of the missing golden girl,
the American beauty and the innocent pregnant wife.
This is a role that she knows will win everywhere.
And America loves pregnant women.
And what might actually be this story's most profound indictment of our societal
sexism, Amy Banks on this fact, there's no woman.
The media loves more than a disappeared white girl. Meanwhile,
she has left Nick to navigate his own new role. One for which he is.
Ill-prepared the sad man whose wife has gone missing. Oh,
and also the main suspect in her disappearance flailing in his part,
Nick mumbles apathetically through a press conference and even gets caught
smiling in a picture with a flirtatious local woman.
Amy took a gamble and she guessed right that Nick smug, easygoing attitude.
And of course his chin would make him the worst possible performer of this role.
Revenge is sweet.
No wonder Amy watches from afar and utter bleak as her underperforming husband
seems to be underperforming himself right into the state penitentiary.
But why not just leave him and or egg his car? Why the whole elaborate plot,
it's actually pretty fitting that Amy is unable to simply disappear and leave it
at that.
Instead the ever able actor needs to entirely rewrite her marriage and recast
the roles to her liking.
We'd argue that this is particularly easy for Amy who seems to have lost sight
of who she is from years of pretending to be the cool girl inventing and
performing comes weirdly to her. Again, this sounds crazy,
but it isn't that different from something a lot of us have done to varying
degrees that is recasting a relationship after it fails painting a
self-preserving narrative that allows us to cope with the reality.
We can't accept once again in the film,
somewhat banal and universal behavior that happens in a lot of semi
dysfunctional relationships gets dialed up until it becomes terrifying and
unrecognizable. But of course, because this is Nick and Amy done,
things are only going to get more demented. Nick finds a veritable bachelors,
then his sister's woodshed, and finally connects the dots.
Amy set him up truly petrified. Nick seeks the help of Tanner bolt,
a professional skeeze ball.
Lawyer bolt helps Nick shift the narrative specifically by directing his act.
He literally trains Nick to one stop seeming like a smug Dick and to
paint himself to also be a victim.
And so Nick goes on TV and becomes the best possible sad husband whose wife has
gone missing. He lies to the world about profoundly missing, loving,
and fearing for Amy and admits to being a lousy partner. And honestly,
he kind of kills it.
I don't care about that anymore. I just want to find my wife.
This is a performance for which Amy was unprepared.
It's exactly this moment that we see Amy's demeanor change. Suddenly.
She seems attracted to Nick. He's outperforming her for once.
And it only took hours of intricate coaching once again. And we hate to say it,
plenty of us know the feeling of performing a perfect sell for our ex in hopes
of winning them back, manifesting everything.
They wanted us to be this kind of performance isn't necessarily rational.
And it definitely isn't particularly healthy, but it's understandable. However,
if you're Nick and you married, Amy,
your performance is also a fight for your life.
So like higher stakes that said for most of us, such a performance,
usually doesn't work out long-term for Nick.
It only seems to persuade Amy because she has so long been desperate for him to
perform to her liking.
And so Amy gets into character for her performance of crime, number two,
promptly, seducing and killing Desi. And then she finally comes home.
And this moment,
Nick and Amy perform a perfect reunion for the press complete with a perfectly
dramatic embrace, which ends with Amy appearing to faint America's beloved,
missing woman and sad husband instantly become America's golden couple of course
there's trouble in this FDIC paradise as they embrace Nick whispers.
Okay.
It's the first time we've seen him call Amy out and performing or vice versa.
Of course only he knows the insane and murderous steps of her depravity.
Then Nick gets to watch his wife play brave survivor in the hospital.
Unlike average dumb woman married to average He-Man this is a role she's chosen
and she milks it for all it's worth.
What's more her flawless performance ensures she won't be tried for her crime
despite detective bony skepticism. Why did you try to buy a gun?
Understandably wary of his killer wife. Nick is not exactly to,
except for new act.
He's even less stoked to commit to the chagrin toning husband.
He performed so well.
And that guy saw on TV. That's the fell in love with. You do know,
I was just telling you what you wanted to hear.
He threatens to leave her multiple times,
but Amy sets him straight on just how dumb that would be.
The way back to her desserts. They'll destroy.
Still.
Nick insists that once the media attention fades,
he's going to write himself off the Nick and Amy show at the subsequent welcome
home. Amy PR stunt, Nick stands beautifully by, as Amy delivers for the crowd,
adding to the show only when she demands it.
And with the most minimal amount of conviction.
[Inaudible].
He begs his lawyer and the detective to help improve the truth,
but both decline he's on his own importantly,
in order for the new Nick and Amy Love's story to work,
they necessarily must corroborate all the awful things Amy wrote about Nick.
I'm going to need those three things to feel safe.
You have to own it.
Amy candidly demands. He play the humbled husband indefinitely,
but the ambiguous line between performance and reality is about to really
disappear near the end. Amy tells Nick that she's pregnant.
The mic hasn't touched her.
Apparently she's commandeered some old blue sample in this way.
She's turned her unhappy life,
field marriage into a real tangible family.
Curious Nick insists that he still going to leave and gets violent.
The idea of performing happy Parenthood with a murderer is it seems too much for
him to take that's. When Amy delivers these blistery words.
The only time you liked yourself was when you were trying to be someone.
In this moment, they show each other, their genuine humanity,
his abusive rage and her manipulative psychopathy. Afterwards,
Nick tries to reason with her.
All we did was respect each other and try to control each other and caused each
other pain.
She merely affirms that's marriage in front of the TV crew.
Nick takes Amy's hand and seems to concede to her demands that their marriage is
an ugly performance. He must partake in,
even if he doesn't fully like the roles been given,
he will have to embody this persona, but he'll get to do so. At Amy side,
they're agreeing to collude in deceiving the world.
We see as much when Nick explained his logic to his sister, Margo,
he says he needs to stay around for the baby,
but Marco sees something more sinister.
You want to stay? I have a responsibility. It's not about what I want anymore.
You want to stay here.
He can't even deny it.
He and Amy have finally found a performance that each can,
except Nick shines in the TV interview,
delivering the perfect act on Amy's behalf.
We're going to be parents.
Todd hall, their marriage is saved. So, uh,
what the there's so creepy and fitting about.
Amy's ultimate revenge against Nick.
It's perfectly corollary to the way she felt forced to perform cool girl.
When they first stated she has masterfully manipulated the situation to force
Nick to forever perform as someone that he's not both with her and with the
world they have through their love each molded and change one another.
And we're left to presume not for the better as Nick reflects in both the
opening and the conclusion of the film.
Marriage has forced each of them to become someone else.
We'd done to each other. What will we do.
Now? As we said earlier,
many people leave this movie with though women be crazy shrub,
but that's a pretty facile interpretation.
Rather we'd argue that this movie is saying something about all of us,
about how we lie and perform and relationships.
I have how those performances to form our very being similarly,
many of us recast ourselves as victims as Amy does and perform ourselves to
perfection in the fallout of a relationship as Nick does. But there's more,
the movie seems to posit a few larger,
ultimately dark things about marriage and romantic love in general.
First that happy relationships are ultimately performances in which the
participants tacitly agreed to put on a good show for the world and often or
each other. It's obviously true of Nick and Amy.
And in some ways it's true for a lot of us.
Nick and Amy with their TV appearance are merely the most extreme conceivable
version of your average couple putting on a happy face for a party after having
a huge fight. That's why it's so creepy.
It takes existing relationship dynamics and just crank them up to 11. Second.
It pauses that romantic relationships are often for the participants themselves,
bonds of questionable genuineness, a dance between honesty and the seat.
It argues that we can never truly know if the person we're with is being
themselves or if they're merely playing a role.
And that maybe we don't even want to know no matter how close we are.
We can't fully understand the nature of our partner, subjectivity,
what they're thinking, what they're feeling or what they have in store for us.
What's more,
it seems to argue that we kind of enjoy the performance and if not too
bad, because there is literally no other way.
And that twice crack is why I have resigned myself to living out my golden
years, surrounded by cats. Kidding, sort of,
but what do you guys think is romantic love inherently deforming to the human
character? Or am I just projecting? Let us know what you think in the comments.
Huge. Thanks to our great patrons for supporting our channel and podcast.
Thanks for watching. And as always peace.
[Inaudible].